[Music]
iran and america have been bitter rivals
for decades
iranian lawmakers chanted death to
america
241 u.s marines died in a separate
suicide bombing
there have been sanctions hostage-taking
proxy wars and
assassinations iran is constantly on the
agenda
these have shaped not just the
relationship between iran and america
but much of the middle east the rivalry
has largely defined the region for the
past
four decades so what's behind the feud
and could president biden help ease
decades of tension
if you want to understand iran's
troubled relationship with america
you need to go back to the 1950s when it
all started in a fight
over oil
at the time iran was home to one of the
biggest oil refineries in the world
abadan but most iranians didn't benefit
from this vast wealth
as the oil fields were controlled by the
british a british employee showing
persians how to shut off the flow of oil
now that the tanks are full this angered
many in iran
and in 1951 iran nationalized the oil
industry
the campaign was led by a nationalist
leader
mohamed mossadek who became prime
minister
[Music]
mozadei came and tried to nationalize
the oil britain considered this theft
the concern was this if they allow iran
to nationalize its oil
what is to prevent iraq saudi arabia and
others
to follow suit and do the same for years
britain tried diplomacy to win
back the oil but talking didn't work
the british needed something more
radical and approached
america for help
as these cia documents show the british
persuaded the americans to join them in
a plot
together they would remove mossdeck and
in doing so
change the course of history
and american spies stirred up violence
in iran
and mossadegh was swept from power that
experience really was a watershed event
in the modern history of iran with
mossadegg gone
the americans needed a leader they could
more easily control
so in 1953 they helped reinstall the
country's king
the shah iran was an important strategic
ally for america as it provided a buffer
against the soviet union
and the americans hoped the shah would
provide access to cheap oil
iran because of the great leadership
of the shop is
an island of stability
in one of the more troubled areas of the
world
but america's support could not protect
the shah from problems at home the
shah was perceived as
somebody who had been reinstated in
power
thanks to this coup so as you can
imagine he was suffering from a crisis
of legitimacy
at the appointed moment the shah of
persia will arrive
the shah was hell-bent on westernizing
iran
he introduced sweeping reforms that
increased access to education
and gave women the vote but some thought
the reforms went too far
eventually that western influence would
anger a lot of people
including the shia clergy
[Music]
and then you had the rest of the
population which was just angry with the
way the shah sort of handles his
business
he was extravagant he was corrupt he
cracked down on any descent
it was becoming clear the shah's days
were numbered
protesters filled the street in violent
clashes with the authorities
there was one man who embodied the
revolutionary movement
the exiled shia cleric ayatollah
khomeini
he returned to iran from paris in
february 1979
and was greeted like a messiah his
return would give the revolution the
final push it needed
the revolution really came like a sudden
tsunami
it was unexpected and it happened in
such a short time span that not even the
ayatollah and his lieutenant
expected you know such a quick victory
within a few months
iran had been declared an islamic
republic which it remains to this day
[Applause]
this was a bitter blow for america but
things were about to get
much worse
[Music]
the shah had left iran before homemani
returned
and months later president jimmy carter
allowed him to come to america for
cancer treatment
which caused outrage in iran and paved
the way for one of the worst
geopolitical fiascos america had ever
suffered
the iran crisis america held hostage
landmark reports like this broke the
news to the nation
the u.s embassy in tehran has been
invaded and occupied by iranian students
angry that the shah had escaped justice
students took a group of u.s
embassy employees hostage demanding that
the shah return to stand
trial the hostages were regularly
paraded in front of the cameras
look at this one america blindfolded
handcuffed that hostage crisis really
traumatized
the american political establishment and
made iran into a very prominent
nemesis it became the poster child for
what we refer to nowadays as
islamic fundamentalism the crisis played
out over 444 days
a rescue attempt went wrong and jimmy
carter failed to win re-election
meanwhile trouble was brewing on the
country's western border
iraq's leader saddam hussein had taken
advantage of the political upheaval to
invade khuzestan
home to the aberdan oil refinery
the iranians retaliated and it turned
into a grueling
eight-year war
america supplied weapons to both sides
prolonging the conflict
but it mainly tried to sway the balance
of power against iran
for america it was a chance to to really
sort of stick it to
the iranians and so they backed up
saddam hussein did everything they could
to sort of tilt the war
slightly to his advantage iran and iraq
attacked each other's ships so the
american navy started to escort oil
tankers in the gulf
and america soon became drawn into
direct fighting with iranian forces
in one incident an american warship shot
an iranian passenger plane out of the
sky whilst under attack
mistaking it for a fighter jet both iran
and iraq
suffered huge losses but on balance iraq
came out on top the conflict hardened
iranian attitudes towards america which
still
shape iran's politics today
iran's current political elite their
baptism
of fire happened during that iran iraq
war the formative years of their life
were spent in the war front so you
cannot now blame them
for having this security-minded outlook
on things
the iran-iraq war was only one in a
series of proxy wars where america was
pitted against iran
another was in lebanon
[Music]
israel a friend of the west invaded
lebanon in 1982
to push out the palestine liberation
organization
or plo
iran intervened in the war to help arm
and train a radical shia militia
iran doesn't have the military might to
fight the us or israel the only way
iran can have an advantage is through
asymmetrical warfare
and this is where proxy groups become
handy
america and other western countries were
drawn
into the war and iran backed suicide
bombers
attacked israeli and western targets
including the u.s
embassy and a marine base in beirut
where hundreds of americans were killed
there was sort of yet another trauma
caused by iran
on america and it sort of went without
retaliation so it really showed up
america's weakness at the time the
militant group behind the bombing didn't
operate
under one name but it soon became known
as hezbollah
or the party of god
it is both a militia and a political
party and dominates lebanon today
throughout the 1980s and 1990s hezbollah
and other proxy groups carried out
multiple attacks
on u.s and especially israeli targets
around the world
but then everything changed
iran had nothing to do with 9-11 but
iran came to experience
the repercussions of the 9 11 attacks
i've never seen nothing like it in my
life
by now iraq under saddam hussein had
also become a foe of america's
in the wake of the attacks america
invaded the country to depose him
this was a crucial moment in america's
relationship with iran
and with americans on their doorstep
iran accelerated its nuclear program
and america was worried iran had been
working to develop missiles the
nuclear threat from iran was sort of
front and center
at this point
[Music]
iran claimed its nuclear ambitions were
for civilian purposes
not for weapons but the west responded
by imposing ever tighter sanctions
the sanctions didn't stop the country
building centrifuges to enrich
uranium which went from zero in 2006
to almost twenty thousand seven years
later
but sanctions particularly those on
iran's oil exports
did [ __ ] iran's economy pushing its
leaders to the negotiating table
and for the first time since the hostage
crisis
america too was willing to negotiate
president barack obama's administration
negotiated a deal with iran's president
hassan rouhani
called the joint comprehensive plan of
action or jcpoa
there were two moderate leaders in each
country that both realized you know you
cannot
start from maximalist demands and expect
the other one to surrender
entirely the deal was groundbreaking
it limited iran's nuclear facilities and
opened it up to more rigorous
inspections
in return for sanctions relief but not
everyone saw it as a success never
ever in my life have i seen
any transaction so incompetently
negotiated
as our deal with iran president donald
trump
withdrew from the deal in 2018
reimposing sanctions
under a policy of maximum pressure
once again raising tensions in the
region
it convinced the iranian hardliners that
you can never trust
america's words people really did suffer
and this gave america
tremendous leverage but donald trump
didn't really use this leverage to any
end
in fact by the end of donald trump's
term iran was closer to a bomb than
at the start of it president biden has
already indicated he would like to
rejoin the jcpoa
the only way out of this crisis is
through diplomacy
but the road ahead is far from certain
iran will elect a new president in 2021
who is widely expected to be more
hardline than his predecessor
making any end to the feud even more
unlikely
the irony of this rivalry is that
american society and iranian society
are much closer to each other than say
american society
and saudi society but their leaders are
held hostage by history
so as much as it would be somewhat
natural for america
and iran to have this rapprochement and
it's going to be very difficult to bring
about
i'm roger mcshane the middle east editor
for the economist
if you want to read more of our coverage
on iran please click the link
thank you for watching don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe
you